podcast special guests in here G Nipsey
representing Cambridge Massachusetts
you already know man he said he had a uh
you know we're gonna keep it Cambridge
with the acapellas today yeah you know
that you know that what's your IG and
all that man my ig's Genesis on
Instagram man type in you already know
we're doing this [__] all the way all
right let's get right to it bro do your
thing bro
this [__] says she love me I am not
romantic I'm toxic as [__] like to take
advantage I'm the king of her world God
of her planning as soon as I get a jug I
get up and vanished only react when she
get lit I'll never Panic don't tell me
where them bins at them with them
Bandits I get a drop on that imma come
through slamming they go even my
brother's mashed potato salmon be hot as
[__] with my little bro said he got hot
on camera you know them people watching
know they trying to jam us [__] I love
trying to rest no I can't stand them his
dumbass bit the cheesy went against the
family that [__] bit the cheese he went
against the family that [__] bit the
cheese he went against the family look
he won the cheese he been against the
family Me birthdays they got 30 shots up
in his camera you don't give a [__]
where you from you can't put no fear me
I [__] make her sing like Mariah
Carey I'm smoking 33 I feel like I'm
leery I got loads of that and I Katy
Perry ain't trying to talk too much
because this [__] getting scary I was on
house arrest when dad died and she left
me teary I'll be talking to the sky
hoping he can hear me and happy I still
got my father but I know that he feel me
when I when I get in my feelings trying
to go slide [__] that's the real me put
your middle fingers in the sky [__] if
you feel me posting my hood every day
knowing they could kill me I hate every
block here every state [__] and I'm
still me let me stop talking on this
[__] I don't think y'all feel me hey I
know you just watched a new freestyle
guess what we're dropping them every
week sometimes more than once a week
Jesus we've been dropping a lot lately
uh shout out to LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week